switching gears i was excited also
because when you say numbers and your
passion and i i get so intimidated by
numbers don't be oh gosh all right well
help me because i read some things and i
want to have you share them with
everybody we're going to give us five
interest we you
are going to give us five interesting
tips on saving money and investing all
right are you ready yep okay rent we
have to pay it housing is what we
you know have to pay on a monthly basis
but you can get ahead if you can pay six
to 12 months of your rent up front so
you don't have to be stressed about
paying your rent on a monthly basis okay
travel you want to go to florida you
want to go somewhere warm go door in the
off season off season the rental prices
are a lot cheaper the weather in miami
is still great and you don't get you're
not around a lot of people which i think
during covid was you know was was
everything all right entertainment tv
subscriptions our viewing habits are
indulgences tips for that you don't have
to pay for it all on your own you have
friends family get into a pot have
someone pay for one subscription
platform in the other because as we know
there's so many nowadays it just offsets
the cost so much gym membership cut it
just cut it we don't need it
and finally let's say
you want to attempt investing
this is where i get completely
intimidated so i'm really excited to
learn from you start with twenty dollars
teach yes
twenty dollars investing is not as
intimidating as i think a lot of people
want to believe when you go to the
grocery store think about it you're
picking up different brands why do you
choose those different brands because
you've done your research you stand by
the company you stand by the product
investing is the exact same way and now
there are so many platforms that provide
trading free commission where you it's
no charge to invest your twenty dollars
so you invest your twenty dollars into a
company where you understand the company
you understand your why
and you go from there it's a lot easier
than i think people make it out to be
are there certains and gambles yeah so
another thing when it comes to investing
understanding your risk tolerance your
risk tolerance is going to dictate how
you invest so if you are someone who
gambles you have a high risk tolerance
and you're probably most likely
investing in new digital currencies such
as crypto if you're someone who is a
little bit more conservative you're
investing in high yield savings accounts
because that will
nothing will happen to your money it
will grow a little bit but you know that
your money is parked and it is safe well
thank you lauren i love getting to talk
about this stuff with you it's so
insightful lauren you can learn even
more from lauren on her amazing show
going public on entrepreneur.com
we will be right back
[Music]
you